Rest in peace, the last of the Marvel-Netflix
superhero series.
On Monday, February 18th, 2019, Deadline delivered
harrowing news to the masses - both The Punisher
and Jessica Jones have been cancelled at Netflix.
The two streaming shows that stood strong
after Netflix pulled the plug on Luke Cage,
Iron Fist, and the much-loved Daredevil in
an unprecedented axe-swinging session in late
2018, The Punisher and Jessica Jones helped
make up the Marvel Television corner of the
streamer's content library.
Their cancellations mean that there are no
longer any non-cancelled, Netflix-backed Marvel
shows on the platform.
The Punisher's axing comes just a month after
the series aired its highly anticipated second
season to critical praise and fanfare from
loyal viewers.
The standing plans are that Jessica Jones
season 3 will air sometime later this year,
giving the series a chance to wrap up its
story, which The Punisher sadly didn't get
to do.
Around the time formal word got out, Punisher
star Jon Bernthal took to his Instagram account
to address the show's cancellation, saying,
in part,
"To all who have served.
All who know loss.
All who love and understand Frank and his
pain.
It has been an honor to walk in his boots.
I'm endlessly grateful to the comic fans and
the men and women of the Armed Services and
law enforcement community who Frank means
so much to."
Marvel Television head honcho Jeph Loeb penned
a letter to Marvel fans, thanking them for
supporting all the shows.
He said, in part,
"Our Network partner may have decided they
no longer want to continue telling the tales
of these great characters… but you know
Marvel better than that.
As Matthew Murdock's Dad once said, 'The measure
of a man is not how he gets knocked to the
mat, it's how he gets back up.'"
Loeb teased at the very end of his letter
that the stories may not completely be over
yet, writing "to be continued…!"
This double cancellation comes as Disney,
which owns Marvel Studios and its small-screen
arm Marvel TV, prepares to roll out its upcoming
direct-to-consumer streaming platform Disney+.
The company has several projects brewing — including
multiple series centered on Marvel Cinematic
Universe heroes Vision and Scarlet Witch,
Loki, and Falcon and the Winter Soldier.
Popular speculation is that Netflix is cutting
ties with the Marvel series so that Disney
can potentially scoop up the shows, revive
them, and air them on Disney+ alongside the
other Marvel shows.
However, there are two factors complicating
this idea: First, according to Variety, there
is reportedly a clause in the original agreement
between Marvel TV and Netflix for Luke Cage,
Iron Fist, Daredevil, and Jessica Jones that
legally bars Marvel TV from using any of the
series' characters in a non-Netflix show or
TV movie for at least two years post cancellation;
and second, according to Deadline, Loeb recently
entered a deal for four television series
and a special with none other than Hulu, another
massive streamer.
If what we know about the terms of Marvel
TV's deal with Netflix is correct, fans shouldn't
expect to see any of the Marvel-Netflix series
get resurrected — for Hulu, Disney+, or
any other platform — for at least two years.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Netflix,
quote, "did not have any ownership stake"
in its Marvel superhero shows, all of which
were owned by Disney.
Netflix cancelling Jessica Jones and The Punisher
now, plus the three other solo shows last
year, signifies that Disney is hoping to reclaim
the series that it doesn't have direct possession
over — and those are the ones on Netflix.
Sad as everyone may be over Netflix doing
away with The Punisher and Jessica Jones,
the two silver linings here are that Jessica
Jones will still release a third season, and
that we certainly haven't seen the last of
Bernthal, who will appear in The Many Saints
of Newark, New Line Cinema's in-development
prequel to The Sopranos.
Additionally, all signs are pointing to Disney
as the future of Marvel TV fare, with executives
at both Disney and Marvel having reportedly
stated that, quote, "the cancelled Netflix
fare could live again on Disney+."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.